>> Jason: IT SEEMS LIKE A
SCRIPT TO ME.
WHILE THE MEDIA HOUSE FROM THE
SIDELINES AND TODAY PRESIDENT
TRUMP URGED DEMOCRATS TO GET
OVER THEIR ANGER AND COME TO
THE TABLE.
WATCH THIS.
>> President Trump: THEY
WERE UNHAPPY WITH THE MUELLER
REPORT.
NO COLLUSION.
NO OBSTRUCTION.
THEY ARE UNHAPPY.
THEY ARE ANGRY ABOUT IT.
THEY HAVE TO GET OVER THE
ANGER.
THEY HAVE TO GET OVER THEIR
ANGER AND GET IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE, DRUG PRICES
AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
>> Jason: JOINING US NOW IS
TRUMP 2020 PRESS SECRETARY
KAYLEIGH McENANY.
CALIFORNIA CONGRESSMAN TOM
McCLINTON AND THE REPUBLICAN
STRATEGIST BRAD BLAKEMAN.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
KAYLEIGH, I'LL START WITH YOU.
I HAVE TO GIGGLE.
THEY THINK THEY ARE GETTING
UNDER THE SKIN OF DONALD
TRUMP.
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
I THINK TRUMP RELISHES IN
THESE SKIRMISHES.
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON IT?
>> YOU ARE RIGHT, JASON.
IT'S SO FUNNY TO WATCH THE
RECORD-BREAKING TIMES THAT
SOMEONE COULD SAY "UNDER
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S SKIN."
AS IF THE DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL
COMMITTEE E-MAILED THE TALKING
POINTS AND THEY ALL PRINTED
THEM OUT AND ECHOED THEM WHICH
IS LIKELY WHAT HAPPENED.
HERE IS THE OPPOSITE, THOUGH.
PRESIDENT TRUMP GETS UNDER
NANCY PELOSI'S SKIN.
HE GETS UNDER THE DEMOCRATS'
SKIN.
MUELLER GOT UNDER THEIR SKIN
WHEN HE EXONERATED THE
PRESIDENT.
THEY ARE TRIGGERED.
THAT IS WHY YOU HEAR
IMPEACHMENT.
HE IS AT THE FASTEST -- IT'S
FASTER THAN RONALD REAGAN AND
HE CONTINUES TO SUCCEED.
HE GETS UNDER NANCY PELOSI'S
SKIN.
INCREDIBLE TO WATCH.
>> Jason: BRAD, LOOK, THE
DEMOCRATS ARE PAINTING
THEMSELVES IN A CORNER, RIGHT?
I DON'T KNOW HOW THEY GET OUT
OF THE CUL-DE-SACS THAT THEY
ARE PUTTING THEMSELVES IN BUT
HOW ARE THE DEMOCRATS GOING TO
PLAY THIS?
>> THEY WILL OVERPLAY IT JUST
LIKE WITH THE ROBERT MUELLER.
THEY ASKED FOR THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
THEY GOT ONE.
THEN THEY SAID WE BELIEVE IN
MUELLER AND WE WILL ACCEPT THE
FINDINGS.
THEY DON'T.
NOW THEY ARE CONTINUING ON THE
DELUSION TO CREATE THE
ATMOSPHERE TO TAKE THE
PRESIDENT DOWN.
NOT ENOUGH TO BE AGAINST
TRUMP.
YOU HAVE TO BEAT HIM AT THE
POLLS.
YOU CAN'T BECAUSE YOU ARE NOT
RUNNING ON A RECORD.
DONALD TRUMP HAS A RECORD.
IT FRUSTRATES THEM TO NO END.
IT'S NOT THEM GETTING UNDER
THE SKIN OF DONALD TRUMP.
THEY ARE CONSUMED BY THE FACT
THAT TRUMP HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL
IN SPITE OF THE EFFORTS TO GET
RID OF HIM.
>> TOM AND I SERVED IN THE
CONGRESS TOGETHER.
WE WERE ELECTED AT THE SAME
TIME.
YOU ARE BRAVER THAN I AM TO
CONTINUE TO SIT THERE IN THE
FACE OF IT.
YOU ARE A CONGRESSMAN FROM
CALIFORNIA SO YOU ARE FAMILIAR
WITH NANCY PELOSI.
WHAT IS YOUR READ ON WHAT IS
SHE DOING AND HOW IS SHE
TAKING POSITIONS THAT SHE IS?
>> I LOVE THE TERM "UNDER HIS
SKIN."
HE IS THE MOST THICK SKINNED
POLITICIAN I HAVE EVER MET.
HE HAS THE SKIN OF AN
ARMADILLO.
THEY FLATTER THEMSELVES IF
THEY THINK THEY ARE GETTING
UNDER HIS SKIN.
EITHER THIS IS VINTAGE TRUMP
DEALSMANSHIP.
THIS REMINDS ME OF THE SCENE
FROM "PATON."
HE IS RANTING AND RAVING AND
THEY PULL HIM ASIDE AND SAID
GENERAL, SOMETIMES THEY DON'T
KNOW WHEN YOU ARE ACTING.
GEORGE C. SCOTT SAYS, "IT'S
NOT IMPORTANT THAT THE MEN
KNOW.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT I KNOW."
THAT MIGHT BE WHAT IS GOING
ON.
OR IT'S HUMAN NATURE.
YOU CAN'T APOLITICABLY
COOPERATE WITH SOMEONE TRYING
TO DESTROY YOU AT THE SAME
TIME.
IF THAT IS THE CASE THEN NANCY
PELOSI HAS A SIMPLE CHOICE.
SHE CAN HAVE A POLICY VICTORY
BY GETTING TOGETHER ON
SOMETHING LIKE INFRASTRUCTURE.
OR SHE CAN KEEP NURSING HER
POLITICAL GRIEVANCES BUT SHE
CAN'T DO BOTH.
>> THAT IS RIGHT.
>> THIS IS THE PROBLEM.
NANCY PELOSI HAS A MEETING
ABOUT IMPEACHMENT.
IMPROMPTU MEETING.
THEN GOES OUT AND ACCUSES THE
PRESIDENT OF VIOLATING THE LAW
AND THEN EXPECTS TO SIT DOWN
WITH HIM IN THE NEXT HOUR?
HUMAN NATURE TO DO WHAT TRUMP
DID.
>> THERE IS NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
THIS WAS A CHARADE.
SOMEONE WHO WANTS TO IN
EARNEST NEGOTIATE AND ENGAGE
IN BIPARTISANSHIP DOES NOT DO
ANY OF THE THINGS THAT YOU
JUST NAMED.
LIKEWISE, IF SHE WANTED TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH
INFRASTRUCTURE THERE WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE ANOTHER MEETING
WHERE THE DEMOCRATS LAID OUT
EXACTLY WHAT THEY WANTED AND
HOW THEY WANTED TO SPEND THE
MONEY.
NANCY PELOSI CANCELED IT.
WE HAVE SEEN IT ON EVERY
ISSUE.
IMMIGRATION, WHEN PRESIDENT
TRUMP PROPOSED A DACA FIX IN
EXCHANGE FOR THE WALL.
THEY DISMISSED IT.
WE SEE IT TIME AFTER TIME.
THEY ARE NOT EARNEST ABOUT
THIS.
IT'S POLITICS.
THEY WANT IMPEACHMENT AND THEY
WANT TO DISENFRANCHISE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Jason: BRAD, I GOT TO
TELL YOU.
IT SEEMS LIKE TRUMP SHOULD BE
WINNING AWARDS FOR HIS
OPENNESS IN THE TRANSPARENCY.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE CLAIMING
THERE IS A COVER-UP.
WHEN TRUMP DOES SOMETHING THEY
CLAIM THE OPPOSITE.
IT'S SO ABSURD THEIR POSITION
TO SAY HE IS COVERING
SOMETHING UP WHEN HE IS AS
OBSERVE AS HE COULD BE IN
ALLOWING ALL THE ACCESS TO THE
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR.
CORRECT?
>> HE INSTRUCTED BARR TO GO
THROUGH THE DOCUMENT TO HAVE
FURTHER TRANSPARENCY ON HOW IT
START AND THE DEMOCRATS ARE
BESIDE THEMSELVES.
THEY NEVER THOUGHT THE
PRESIDENT WOULD RESPOND THE
WAY HE DID.
NOW WE'LL FIND OUT WHAT WAS
BEHIND THE DOSSIER, HOW IT WAS
GATHERED, THE INFORMATION AND
INCLUDING MORE INFORMATION
ABOUT THE TREACHERY THAT WAS
HAPPENING AT THE SENIOR
LEADERSHIP OF THE F.B.I.
BE CAREFUL WHAT YOU WISH FOR.
>> Jason: ADAM SCHIFF SAYING
WHAT THE PRESIDENT DID IS
UN-AMERICAN.
WHAT IS YOUR READ ON IT?
>> IT'S ABSOLUTELY AMERICAN.
LOUIE BRANDI SAID IT BEST.
SUNLIGHT IS THE BEST OF
DISINFECTANTS.
IT'S BECOMING CLEAR WE HAD THE
EMBRYO OF A POLICE STATE
GROWING IN OUR INTELLIGENCE
AGENCIES.
IN OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES AND AT THE I.R.S.
I.R.S. PRAYING
I.R.S. PREYING ON THE ORDINARY
AMERICANS BECAUSE OF THE
POLITICAL BELIEFS AND
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AT THE
HIGHEST LEVELS MISUSING THEIR
POWERS.
FIRST, TO INTERVENE IN OUR
NATIONAL ELECTION.
WHEN THEY FAILED TO DO THAT TO
UNDERMIND CONSTITUTIONALLY
ELECTED PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> CONGRESSMAN, ONE OF THE